[Applause]
good morning first of all happy mother's
day to any mother here a very special
good morning and welcome to this MBA
recognition ceremony for 788 amazing
people they are the members of the class
of 2017 let me be the first person to
congratulate you give yourselves a round
of applause collectively your class is
extraordinary and it's extraordinarily
diverse you come from 66 different
countries as far as China Korea India
France and Australia
you speak fifty-eight different
languages and dialects including Arabic
Dutch German Portuguese Russian and I am
told English you come from countless
industries and professional backgrounds
and among you of course our consultants
and Finan seers yes but also Yogi's and
cooks and scuba divers and cyclists and
musicians explorers and entrepreneurs of
every stripe
I hope this morning that you take pride
in all that you have accomplished six of
you have done exceptionally well
academically during your time at the
school and a graduating I said
exceptionally
those six of you are graduating with a
GPA of 10.0 or higher congratulations
today today for all of you you join a
vibrant community of alumni who are
decision makers and leaders at the
center of business they're entrepreneurs
they're Industry pioneers they're game
changers there are 44,000 individuals
who do both influential and important
work work that changes the world you
have been working fulfilling this role
since the day you arrived on campus at
orientation we all on the faculty and
staff challenge you to be active and
engaged members of the community and you
more than met this challenge on campus
whether by serving your classmates
through formal channels like the peer
advisor program and student government
playing a role in successful Colombia
forever or women's week lending an
invaluable voice at club meetings or
events or sharing your ideas about the
MBA experience but today's special today
is set aside so that we the faculty and
administration at Columbia Business
School together of course with your
family and friends can celebrate you
celebrate your accomplishments here and
wish you continued success in your new
roles as alumni I know that you leave
the school well equipped as leaders as
thinkers ready to have an impact and I
look forward to seeing the change you're
going to affect not only in your
professional lives but your communities
I want you to take a moment with me
though and applaud some people who have
supported you in your time here not only
your faculty colleagues here at the
school but more especially your families
individually individually you've been
exposed to thought leadership that is
constantly informed in real-time by a
global business environment
groundbreaking research from the
school's faculty influences business
practice in nearly every sector a
transformative curriculum has taught you
to create and find opportunity in any
environment and thanks to the school's
unique position in the heart of New York
City you've been able to benefit from
simply unrivaled access to myriad
industries and visionary business
leaders as well as high-impact
internships at a wide range of the best
firms in finance social enterprise and
retail just to name a few the reputation
the strength of Columbia Business School
has equipped you with the knowledge and
access you're going to need to make a
lasting impact on business and beyond as
an alum it's going to provide you with
the connections to support and foster
the creativity you already have invite
entrepreneurial thinking and frankly
open doors to opportunity these tools
are going to give you the confidence the
ability to succeed on your own terms and
you couldn't be better prepared for the
challenges that lie ahead but I have to
be honest with you with the rewards of
your MBA come responsibilities what does
it mean to be a graduate of Columbia
Business School we all hope and expect
that as you rise in your career that
you're inspired to give back and come
back to see new generations of students
and see the support that you received in
your time here and recognize your role
as proud stewards of the Columbia
Business School brand that you both tap
into and add value to the community
fortunately you have many extraordinary
examples to follow in your fellow alumni
well mine like Donnell Baird class of
2013 Donnell is tackling two problems he
witnessed growing up in Bedford
Stuyvesant
chronic unemployment and high energy
costs his company blocked power trains
unconventional employees to install
energy-efficient technology for small
businesses and nonprofits in underserved
communities
slashing both energy costs and co2 in
2012 he received the echoing green and
Open Society Foundations
black male achievement fellowship which
supports work to improve the life
outcomes of African American men and
boys in the United States another
example can be found in sha Zhi viscera
class of a 4 sha Zhi founded happy
family the leading premium organic baby
and toddler food brand in the United
States in 2011 happy family ranked
number 2 among all food and beverage
companies in ink magazine's annual
listing of the 500 fastest growing
companies the same year she was named
one of the top 10 female entrepreneurs
she launched the idea in business school
and now serves on the school's board and
has sold a controlling stake in happy
family to denote in 2013 meanwhile when
John Stein class of Oh 9 was a novice
investor he thought he could do better
than what his economics professors had
drilled into it by the way that's never
true what he was worried about is why is
the market portfolio the optimal
portfolio to own so after his first
stock pick Enron failed and after
deciding to heed his professors advice
removed
he created betterment an online
investment advisor which offers
consumers a better more convenient way
to invest in the market portfolio with
an emphasis on design and ease of use
and customer centric experience
betterment has been dubbed the Apple of
Finance today more than 200,000
customers invest more than 6 billion
dollars with betterment but there's so
many more you might think of Jeri spire
or Lea Cooperman Henry Kravis Lulu Wong
Robert Smith or Russ Carson
shelley lazarus tracy travis and sally
Krawczyk warren buffett art Sandburg
Mario gabelli
Jerry Jason dong-bin Shin and Lou
Frankfurt Vikram Pandit and James
Foreman Jaime Kern Lima John Martin Tim
Campos and I won't name the other 44,000
but all amazing that community this
community it's your network it's a
powerful asset that you can and I hope
will leverage for a lifetime so stay
connected to it reach out to each other
often give back and use the resources
that it provides you have richly earned
it now back to today what happens now in
one sense the familiar sense you will
graduate you become part of this alumni
network that I just spoke about all over
the world you go from being a student to
being an alum making his or her mark
like Anthony agony class of 89 leader of
the Alumni Club of Orange County who
this Wednesday at the University
commencement will win the Alumni metal
service to the University but it's
precisely these thoughts in mind that we
have when we celebrate your graduation
from a great business school great
business school is a world-class
institution that marries theory with
real-world practice in a global
community of both creative and diverse
individuals that's you it's my honor to
be a faculty member here frankly it's my
honor to have directly worked with many
of you and I'm proud to be your Dean but
I have to tell you I prefer a different
word to graduate on days like this I
prefer the more old-fashioned word
commencement because it has an explicit
reference to beginnings and transitions
you will begin soon a different kind of
life of engagement in business and
society you have so much to contribute
to both and I know that you will but I
have something to share with you most of
all
most of all never forget what a noble
calling business itself is and the power
that lies within each and every one of
you to transform lives not only of
business leaders entrepreneurs but also
your fellow alumni communities and
frankly nations around the globe I want
you to remember with me this morning
that your MBA is a master of choices
what matters most to me what matters
most to my colleagues here what matters
most to your family and friends is not
the change jingling in your pockets
after commencement but the change you
are about to make in the world
congratulations again to all of you give
yourselves another round of applause
it is now my great pleasure to welcome
our distinguished speaker this morning
Joyce Roche Joyce is an author and the
former president and CEO of Girls Inc
she served as the president and chief
operating officer of Carson products
company and vice president of Global
Marketing at Avon products after earning
her MBA from Columbia in 1972 she joined
Avon where she broke new ground becoming
avons first african-american female vice
president the first african-american
vice president of marketing and the
company's first vice president of global
marketing she's appeared in Business
Week stories multiple times featured on
the cover of Fortune and black
enterprise named her as one of the 21
women of power and influence in
corporate of America and one of the 40
most powerful black executives in 2014
the Financial Times selected Joyce is an
outstanding corporate director something
she richly deserves and the Columbia
women in Business Club awarded her its
distinguished alumna award Joyce has
received wide acclaim for her new memoir
the Empress has no clothes conquering
self-doubt to embrace success which
documents her struggles with impostor
syndrome and her advice to other high
achievers who have struggled with Dell
she's an inspiration both on the page
but also in the boardroom serving on the
boards of directors of AT&T Macy's
Tupperware brands and Dr Pepper Snapple
Group Doc diet dr. pepper is my favorite
training
Joyce has paved the way for many women
in business she is a tremendous leader
author and mentor it's my pleasure it's
my honor to have her with you today here
with you today please help me in
welcoming Joyce Roche
Wow good morning and again happy
Mother's Day to all the mothers in the
audience Thank You Dean Hubbard's not
only for that generous introduction but
for your support over the years I also
have to thank Monica Kelly the student
the Student Government Association and
the entire class this is school class of
2017 for reaching out to me to be
today's speaker it's truly an honor to
have been selected as today's speaker
especially as we come to the end of the
Columbia Business School centennial
celebration let me also thank the
faculty and staff or the business school
and like Dean Hubbard the families and
friends of all of the graduates today
would not have been possible without
your guidance support and encouragement
so thank you
to the graduates congratulations as I
said I'm deeply honored to have been to
be here with all of you as you celebrate
this important day and I gain I thank
you for the privilege of addressing you
finally I want to congratulate all of
the Award winners because you are truly
outstanding well we are living in
interesting times to say the least
but I believe that the times are always
interesting for the people living
through them what distinguishes each of
us is whether we see the opportunities
in our times are only the challenges
dr. Benjamin Mays the great educator
taught that God has sent every man and
woman into the world to do something
unique something distinctive and if he
or she doesn't do it it will never get
done and the world will be the loser to
live fully we must embrace this
conviction our most important job in
this world is to discover and bring
forth the unique gifts that each of us
have the quest for purpose isn't always
easy
but it's always worthwhile now more than
ever our world needs people who have
spirit energy and vision people who are
committed to making a difference I
learned about the meaning of purpose
from my Aunt Rose and my mother who've
been the most important teachers
throughout my life they would say to me
if you're strong enough to follow your
heart there's nothing in this world that
can stop you growing up as an
african-american girl in the New Orleans
of 1950s and 60s
I needed that encouragement every day as
I faced those two big isms
of sexism and racism I knew getting an
education was the only chance that I had
of bettering myself and of fighting back
against a system of inequality in
college I was studying to be a math
teacher an extremely laudable career but
it was only one of the few options I
thought I had available to me
however the civil rights movement and
affirmative action were opening new
doors for African Americans and for
women and transforming the consciousness
of the country so in my senior year when
two of my male friends were admitted to
MBA programs and Ivy League institutions
I decided to go beyond what was expected
and acceptable I took a risk and I made
up my mind to pursue a business degree I
applied to Columbia Business School and
I received a fellowship this was an
exciting but a scary proposition for me
I had never been in a majority
institution and I've never competed
against people who didn't look like me
not only was Columbia fiercely
competitive there were only a handful of
women in my class and even fewer
african-americans a situation I am
extremely happy to say looks a lot
different today for me the risk paid off
thank you
at Columbia I discovered a discipline I
knew nothing about and it set me on a
career path I'd never could have
imagined as a result of this new path in
marketing I achieve many first in my
career including the opportunity to join
several high-profile corporate boards by
all measures I have achieved outstanding
professional success but even in the
midst of all of that success I carried
the belief that I didn't deserve it and
sooner or later I would be found out as
an impostor that dread drove me to work
harder and harder and to constantly
worried that I would stumble and they
would find out that it was not smart
enough or whatever enough to be where I
was I recently read an interview by
Oprah Winfrey where she said I was most
terrified of not being enough not being
good enough pretty enough skinny enough
just not enough like Oprah I ultimately
learn to quiet that voice of self-doubt
but increasingly I began to hear the
insistent whispers in my soul that I
wanted to bring more of my gifts into
the world I love my work but at the end
of the day that's what it had become
work I now wanted a passionate
engagement to give full voice to what
was in my heart after a lot of thought
and soul-searching I decided to take
everything that I had learned in my
years in corporate America and to help
use to help drive social change in this
country that's when I joined girls Inc
an organization that's been an inspiring
and empowering girls in this country
since 1860 for the 10 years I spent at
Girls Inc were blessing they provided
the passionate engagement that I had
longed for and it allowed me to finally
question and ultimately let go of those
impostor beliefs I knew then that I was
exactly the
right person in the right place at the
right time and that I did deserve my
place at the table the experience of
confronting my imposter fears later in
life made me realize that too many of us
keep our gifts hidden for fear that will
not be accepted or acceptable I went on
to write a book about the imposter
syndrome in the hopes of helping others
tackle their self-doubt much earlier
than I was able to do it and to let them
know that they're not alone and to
encourage them to bring all of their
gifts into the world so that's my
message today share all of your gifts
our world certainly needs you so as you
enter or re-enter your careers tap into
your personal power to find your passion
and your purpose whatever it might be
and have the courage to take a risk to
pursue that passion as Ralph Waldo
Emerson finally famously said to leave
the world a bit better whether by a
healthy child a garden path or redeemed
social condition to know that even one
life breathe easier this is to have
success and I wish all of you much
success again congratulations
thank you so much Joyce it is now my
pleasure to welcome our student speaker
Michael Conway
though he has been overseas numerous
times Mike is a New Yorker raised in
Queens and a graduate of the United
States Military Academy at West Point
after earning his degree in civil
engineering Mike commissioned as an
officer in the United States Army where
he served in a variety of leadership
roles earned several recognitions and
eventually left with an appointment as
captain in 2015 Mike's been a highly
engaged member of the Columbia community
he served as cluster chair for g17 and
participated in the exchange program
with London Business School after
graduation he's at the graduation he's
headed back overseas for an ethics
fellowship in Europe followed by a
position as a consultant at McKinsey
when he returns to the States
he's thrived in every possible way at
Columbia I'm pleased to have him as a
speaker here today please join me in
welcoming Mike Conway
good morning Dean Hubbard Dean Malone
Dean Crawford distinguished faculty
parents family and friends and of course
the MBA class of 2017 I would first like
to thank the Office of Student Affairs
and most importantly my classmates for
allowing me this opportunity to speak on
our behalf
I'm truly very humbled and very honored
to be standing up here today before I
forget I would also like to wish all the
mothers in the audience that happy
Mother's Day often often our mothers our
fiercest supporters and our most trusted
confidant and to everyone who has been
there for us in so many different
capacities over the past two years
without your support and without your
encouragement we wouldn't be here today
anyone who has spent a day at Columbia
Business School or CBS for short has
become very familiar with the hashtag
why CBS for most of us we were first
introduced that expression when we
entered that very question on our
application I faced over the course the
past two years that expression has
become more of a symbol a symbol of the
incredible experiences we have shared
experiences like first meeting our
learning teams PA week traveling the
world on shaysing trips lecturers like
Warren Buffett and hideki matsui
sampling classmates cooking skills and
supper clubs immersing in New York City
and of course taking the one train
trying to find a seat in Watson the
delicious your Esteli lunches
follies videos like those immortalizing
stroke those pieces and how CBS is
pretty cool for V school and all the
different aspects that make each cluster
just a little weird these have all
brought to life what it is meant to be a
student here at Columbia Business School
as we prepare to walk across the stage
and leave Columbia Business School that
expression why CBS now takes on a new
meaning for us
why CBS now becomes an affirmation a
testament to the competence the
potential and the character of CBS
graduate as MBA recipient each and every
one of us will re-enter the workforce in
a position of greater responsibility we
will be looked upon not just for our
business acumen but also to mentor and
to guide the junior members of our
organizations by nature of this degree
each of us is leaving business school
expected to lead doctoring the Corps
professor Donaldson said something to a
student in global economics that has
resonated with me ever since
when a student raised his hand to ask
the question and the professor didn't
hear what he had said professor
Donaldson didn't ask him to repeat the
question instead he addressed him and
said speak boldly for you about to be a
business leader that response always
stood out and frankly I'm glad it did
because never have those words rang
truer than today
we were about to re-enter a world that
is uncertain at a time when our country
and our world needs good leaders as we
all know the world faces complex
problems problems that are magnified by
the rapid unfiltered spread of
information and reinforced by divisive
nough Centel arity contrary to popular
belief however the polarity that we face
today
is not really all that unique
in fact each generation is tested in
their own way we need only to look to
our parent sitting here in the audience
and think how their generation
championed the civil rights era and
navigated the divisive this surrounding
Vietnam and the anti-establishment
movement more broadly our parents
generation in the international
community spearheaded changes
conflicting political ideologies
threatened cultural identities across
the world if we look at our grandparents
generation we remember them today as the
greatest generation for the sacrifices
that they made and for their unity as
the country came together when faced
with political uncertainty and war what
divides us today might be different but
the challenge is the same the challenge
is that across every generation we see
how uncertain times require a new
generation of leaders to emerge we are
leaving Colombia at a point in time and
in positions to be those leaders we have
spent the past two years preparing to be
those leaders who by our example will
influence and by our courage leave right
now our class is defined by our
camaraderie and by the shared
experiences we've had over the past two
years most recently a lot of those
memories might be rollerblading in a wig
in a mustache in Staten Island walk in
the streets of New York on one of our
various food tours or maybe even our top
five or some memories from Puerto Rico
[Applause]
on a more serious note the challenge
before us is to be remembered by the
actions that we start taking tomorrow
there was a class at West Point the
class of 1915 that is universally
accepted as a class that is more
distinguished than any other class in
West Point's history that class is known
as the class the Stars fell on a
distinction bestowed upon them for the
individual leaders that emerge from that
class to include General Eisenhower a
former president of Columbia University
and a 34th president United States and
also for the class's collective actions
when they were faced with the
unprecedented challenges during the
world wars of the 20th century that
class rose to their challenge unlike any
other class will we to rise to our
challenge and become defined by the
actions that we take to go even a step
further could it be possible that we
become the next greatest generation
seems a rather bold assertion but
standing here today I think about what
that distinction means and why we hold
our grandparents generation in such high
esteem I think in my own grandparents oh
my dad said my grandfather was an
immigrant who lived in an attic having
came a bartender here in New York and in
turn send all three of his children of
college how my mom's died my grandfather
was an orphan who enlisted in the army
and became a 5 New York City fireman and
it turns an all for his children of
college I think of them and countless
other examples of how across the
greatest generation there was a shared
sense of selflessness hard work and an
acceptance of a greater cause and a
higher purpose for many of us this
degree represents a lot of first-first
for ourselves first for our families
first of our communities
but for each and every one of us this
degree represents a gift an opportunity
and also a responsibility for us to
emulate what defines the greatest
generation we have the obligation to use
this opportunity it is now our
responsibility to be the voice for those
who don't have a voice and the voice for
those who don't have the courage to use
their own voice with this degree we must
now demonstrate what why CBS represents
there have been a few other iconic
expressions that looking past looking
back over the past two years I've really
stuck out expressions like we all rise
allies make Watson great again FOMO fear
of missing out
yo Bo the only b-school once yo so the
only survey once we all know that wasn't
true and of course Yolo you only live
once well on like yo so yo Bo and Yolo
are true we won't be going back to
business school and each of us only has
just one life to live it is now up to us
to take the bold actions expected of
business leaders with bold action comes
risk yet good leaders aren't simply a
result of a series of good decisions no
one gets them all right
sometimes handling a bad decision best
demonstrates the person's character
sometimes a wrong decision is humbling
and a reinforcement that leaders must
have humility and empathy we will be
placed in positions that require our
decisions it is on us to always remember
that there are people who stand on the
other end of those decisions Columbia
has demonstrated the necessity of taking
bold actions and leading with competence
but also the necessity of respecting a
person's dignity and building bridges
where bridges can be built through our
travels over the past two years we have
seen how some people can have so much
while others so little may we have the
courage to be bold the humility to lead
with compassion and the empathy to lead
with understanding on the night before I
left for the army I was in my room
talking with my dad during that
conversation he gave me two pieces of
advice that I never forgot
he said one don't let them change you
and two never forget where you came from
I now offer his advice to everyone here
as we re-enter the corporate world it is
imperative that we stay true to who we
are it is imperative that we remember
the values and the professional
standards that we learned and refined
here at this institution let us be the
standard bearers that others want to
emulate equally let us not forget the
journey that we've made to get to this
point while with sacrifice and hard work
comes reward let us not lose sight of
the opportunity that we've been given an
opportunity that so many don't even
dream of let us remember that to those
to whom much is given much is expected
here's been my distinct honor to address
you today to the mba class of 2017 I
wish each of us success and fulfillment
but I would like to leave us however
with a question will we be a class that
Stars fall on could we actually become
the next greatest generation will we be
bold enough will we demonstrated what it
means what somebody asks the question
why CBS
good afternoon I'm pleased to present
two Awards the Singhvi prize and the
lira award that reflect the values of
inclusion and recognition within the
Columbia Business School community the
first award is the Tsing V prize for
scholarship in the classroom the
recipient is selected by the graduating
students and awarded to a faculty member
who exemplifies excellence in the
classroom based on his or her dedication
to teaching ability to communicate
knowledge and encourage students the
2017 winner of the Sigma V prize is
Professor Bruce uh sure professor of
professional practice
professor of professional practice and
the Elizabeth restricter 86 and Mark
Tegel ogly 86 faculty director of the
tamer Center for social enterprise
Professor Asher ranks amongst the very
best professors at CBS students
consistently comment on his ability to
seamlessly integrate theory and practice
his class is tied together Finance
social and environmental issues they are
engaging thoughtful and interactive
Professor Asher
relays a comprehensive understanding of
issues that will affect us and the
generations to come
prior to joining CBS Professor Asher was
the CEO for Echo Securities Group plc
and the co-founder and CEO of Treasury
Connect LLC please join me in
acknowledging our Singhvi Prize winner
professor Bruce
thank you this award is a great honor
and it means a lot to me
I believe that teaching is a privilege
and I've had the special privilege of
teaching many of you in the past two
years I just want to say thank you for
that congratulations to all of you
our next award is the Robert W we reward
the Robert W leer award is presented to
a faculty or administrator for service
to the students above and beyond the
call of duty the 2017 winner of the
Robert W Lee reward is Elan Crawford
assistant dean and Dean Crawford has
been instrumental in bringing the
community closer together this year
Dean Crawford has become renowned for
her commitment to transparency
partnership and inclusion it's no
surprise that students nominated her
with an overwhelming majority
she's collaborated with students in the
creation of new programming including
our community matters and the state of
the school she has been a champion for
ensuring that school-wide events are
accessible and affordable
Dean Crawford has had a truly amazing
and positive impact on the student
experience an alumna of Teachers College
Dean Crawford joined CBS as Dean of
Students and assistant dean for the MBA
program in January 2015
previously being Crawford held several
leadership roles at Villanova NYU and in
the corporate sector please join me in
congratulating this year's Robert W er
Service Award recipient Dean salon
Crawford
thank you thank you as always you guys
are full of energy thank you to the
class of 2017 for this amazing award I
want to leave you with a few important
messages today we will always be family
and CBS will always be your home so
protect your house and don't do anything
to compromise the integrity of the brand
or your own personal integrity I know
you value your friendships so like you
have for the last two years continue to
support each other personally and
professionally second I want to leave
you with the words of shirley Chisholm
who once said you don't make progress by
standing on the sidelines whimpering and
complaining you make progress by
implementing ideas I'm so proud of what
we've been able to accomplish together
like you have during your time at CBS my
expectation is that you will continue to
innovate make changes lead and implement
ideas in your next destination and on a
personal note thank you for challenging
me on a daily basis thank you for making
me laugh and sometimes cry but most
importantly thank you for inspiring me I
am so grateful I'm so proud of you I
love you all and thank you so much for
this amazing award
we're pleased now to acknowledge the
student award recipients for the class
of 2017 students are selected by the
administration and their peers for
community service and academic awards
we'll start with the community and
service awards Columbia Business School
is is proud to recognize the recipients
of the following the New York alumni
club award which is given on the basis
of exceptional academic achievement
outstanding character participation in
school affairs and potential for civic
business and professional leadership the
Heffernan Award for service which is
given to graduating students who have
served the school behind the scenes and
contributed to the academic standards
operations spirit and integrity of the
business school community these awards
are selected by the administration the
Business School student service award
honors students who have made
outstanding contributions to the
business school community as selected by
you the graduating class when I call
your names I'll ask each recipient to
come up to receive your honor and
recognition first this year's New York
Alumni Award recipient is Sid vana SWAT
don't go too far you are also being
recognized with the Business School
student service award congratulations
recipients of both the Heffernan award
for service and the business student
school service award our Samantha Lally
and Annie curdle
[Applause]
recipients of the business school
service awards are Alicia hi Oh Michael
Shapiro and Kareem Selma
[Applause]
the Heffernan award for service is
presented to Michael Gadara Charles
Pippin Clifton Smith am ray TECA shelf
Katherine Watson Hillary witless Todd
Whitman you tell llamada Eric Yin je and
Simon Trendelenburg
[Applause]
in addition to his Heffernan award simon
is also presented with the award for
academic excellence in management by
professor todd chick
I am pleased to continue the awards
presentation by recognizing the
recipients of the academic awards which
were selected by faculty presented by
Dean Katherine Philips the human Hubert
Award in marketing recognizes the
graduating student with an outstanding
record in the study of marketing who
shows promise of future contributions to
the field this year's recipient is
Patrick Hugin
[Applause]
presented by professor Kemal g-diddy the
amina elliot webster memorial award in
marketing is given to a graduating woman
who has shown overall academic
excellence in the area of marketing this
year's recipient is Karin Alper
presented by Professor Jonathan Glover
the Robert H Montgomery prize in
accounting is awarded for excellence in
the area of accounting this year's
recipient is Christopher Cunningham
presented by Professor Dan Wang the
Robert and Jacqueline Whillans tax
research project award is awarded for
superior skills in the area of tax
theory and practice or research this
year's recipient is Alexander Levy
runner-up our Shan palette
and Oleg mystic who is unable to join us
today
presented by professor Jose zubizarreta
the award for academic excellence in
decision risk and operations is
presented annually to a graduating
student who'd emirates demonstrates
outstanding skills in the field this
year's recipient is morgan Shattuck
[Applause]
presented by Professor Wei Zheng the Eli
Ginsberg memorial prize is presented
annually to graduating students who have
done outstanding work in the fields of
economics or human resources this year's
recipients are nathaniel jerusalem and
eduardo credence
[Applause]
presented by Professor Bruce Kogut the
Nathan Ganser prize for social
enterprise is presented annually to
graduating students who best
demonstrates dedication to the public
and nonprofit sector and who exemplify
inner strength and personal integrity
the recipients this year are Nisha
Prasad and kau shakes Kappa gun salute
presented by Professor Kent Daniel the
Suresh Balarama prize is presented
annually to a graduating student who has
demonstrated outstanding work in the
field of Finance this year's recipient
is an upon nigh on
lastly we'd like to recognize this
year's recipient for the Campbell Award
to celebrate all who build Columbia
University spirit the University
trustees and the Board of Columbia
Alumni Association in the CIA
established the award given to a
graduating student at each school who
shows exceptional leadership and
Columbia spirit as exemplified by the
late Bill Campbell chair emeritus
university trustee outstanding alumnus
and CAA co-founder this year's recipient
is Hilary wool
it is not now my distinct pleasure to
turn the podium over to one of the co
presidents of the student government
Charles Eberley to share his remarks
[Applause]
good morning and happy Mother's Day
almost exactly two years ago today my
friend a fellow Marine Chris Norgren was
killed when his helicopter slammed into
the side of a mountain in Nepal Chris
and his crew were then delivering
disaster aid to the victims of an
absolutely devastating earthquake in the
aftermath of his death a letter emerged
that he had penned some years earlier to
the then-current students of his former
high school in that letter he said you
all have amazing futures directly in
front of you so I will give you three
new tasks and as we sit here today with
undoubtedly amazing futures in front of
us those three tasks could not be more
appropriate to revisit one
he said do something every single day
that challenges you physically mentally
or emotionally to find your
transcendental purpose that is find the
one thing bigger than yourself the one
thing that gets you out of bed every day
and when you find that one thing devote
yourself to it three make every team
organization a relationship that you're
a part of better for being a part of it
our time at Columbia Business School has
certainly given us the skills capacity
optimism and experiences to do all three
is the second task however the finding
of our transcendental purpose that most
of us have found and continue to find to
be our biggest challenge many of us will
find our passion in business but perhaps
for some of us we will find our passion
in family government academia or service
to community some of us will find
passion right away but for many of us it
may take us a bit longer and although we
will find our purpose in different ways
our passion in different places it's
okay
remember to take your cues in signals
from within rather than from the herd
regardless of the transcendental purpose
we will each commit to or the path in
which we take to ultimately discover it
we should all expect that after today
the immediate expectations placed upon
us will be high
we should also trust that we are very
well prepared the expectation that is
mba's we will contribute meaningfully
id8 thoughtfully communicate effectively
and lead compassionately will be
ever-present going forward embedded in
this great expectation is great
privilege it is the privilege to create
impact it is this privilege that will
give us meaning in the very things we do
it is something many people long for the
careers before us holds substantial and
complex challenges challenges we do not
yet have solutions for however the
expertise needed in that moment can only
come from experience but the mental
framework requisite first success has
been already imparted in us over these
past two years and we'll find in the
wake of these challenges our
transcendental purpose will become
increasingly clear we will no doubt be
challenged to our core by these
inevitable complexities never forget at
that moment when these challenges appear
we are not and will never be alone the
relationships we have made here will
endure as we remain ever united in our
commitment to our Columbia Business
School community thank
I'm now pleased to introduce my fellow
co-president of Student Government and
friend Sid V suna
so my friends we've made it to the end
now it's been an interesting couple of
years right here some of the things we
did we got through great non-disclosure
which some of us took as classes don't
matter then we managed to convince our
families that we needed to travel during
classes to find ourselves we even
invented a spectator sport called bad
decisions on social media now all that's
standing between us and that 18-hour day
desk job is this speech love it so I've
been going back and forth over the past
few weeks thinking of what exactly I
should be saying to you it's kind of
hard to do that when you've exclusively
relied on your accent to get through
b-school as one of my dear friends wrote
in my lead 360 review back in full 2015
Sid is very good at coming to America
and exploiting his British accent
he's not done yet he says I should
imagine he is somewhat unremarkable back
home in England he nailed it smartest
guy in the room right there I mean I
even asked so many of you for thoughts
from what you'd like to hear which was
the worst mistake ever because if you
ask more than a few MBAs for their
opinion on anything oh my god it's just
more questions and answers it was it was
it wasn't good so I did what most people
do and I thought to myself what would I
want to hear right and the answer ended
up being quite easy all the juiciest
gossip from the last two years I mean
seriously why all swear I take this job
if not to be at the very center of
gossip so look I'm going to share some
stories of the reception after this I
just have one announcement to make
on behalf of Michael Isha wristbands not
required okay
so nervous I'm nervous okay so now that
I've successfully wasted the first
minute I do have something meaningful to
offer you today my friends I want to
speak about valuing the people around us
for me this has been the single biggest
lesson from my time at CVS so what do I
mean by this well two things really the
first is being compassionate and the
second is being grateful as Millennials
we can often be quick to judge with not
too much information we do after all
live in the age of Twitter however we've
seen with recent events that
presumptious leadership can be
disastrous
now more than ever the world needs
leaders who are compassionate who build
bridges and this must start with an
understanding of those around us valuing
them as individuals we here at CBS are
extremely fortunate to have CBS matters
for those of you who aren't aware CBS
masters is a chance for students here to
present about the things that matter
most to them it's one of my most
favorite aspects of the Columbia
groans because the chance to hear from
our classmates about the intimate
aspects of their lives is truly a
privilege
I remember being sat in one of cluster
ecbs Mathers back in fall 2015 I didn't
really know that custom ate very well he
struck me as someone who was kind of shy
and reserved but with awesome hair a few
minutes into his talk we discovered that
he had six adopted sons in Mozambique he
described each one with so much warmth
and affection that by the end of his CVS
masses we really felt like we had known
him forever that was one of the most
eye-opening experiences for me in my
time here in just 20 minutes we
understood him on such a deep level we
understood his motivations his
inspirations his hopes and his dreams
now imagine if we had CBS Mathers at
work we would feel so much more valued
if we were better understood by our
colleagues and bosses we would also
benefit from being able to understand
those who work around us so that we can
interact and potentially lead more
effectively as the leaders of tomorrow
showing compassion and valuing those
around us is going to be fundamental
similarly being grateful is crucial each
of us has made the journey to this very
moment carrying with us the good wishes
of our families our friends and our
colleagues just look around you we're
surrounded by people who love us we have
so much to be grateful for but in the
hustle and bustle of b-school in New
York we can often forget to express that
gratitude remember my friends these
individuals have been core to helping us
get to where we are today this is only
going to continue into our working lives
the road is very long my friends and we
are only at the beginning deadlines will
have to be met promotions will have to
be earned and that next opportunity
can't come fast enough none of these
things are going to be achieved without
other people even just getting through
b-school I couldn't have done it without
my family my friends the amazing members
of student government acts
and of course my lovely wife so on this
day of recognition I ask us all to thank
the people around us who have helped us
achieve this milestone in our lives I
ask you to continue being grateful for
there will be people who come into our
lives to help us in ways we don't yet
expect and so my friends as we count
these precious few seconds we have left
to students I would like to take this
opportunity to expect extend my most
sincere gratitude to you for your
support this year it really has meant
the world it has been such a privilege
to get to know you all and I really
can't wait to see what lies ahead for
all of us as we embark on our leadership
journeys let us make sure that we value
the people around us let us spread our
success cry together allow setbacks and
share our happiness the world needs this
leadership from us now more than ever I
hope that one day several years from now
when Manhattanville is finally built we
too can get together in some corner of
the world
to share our happiness and our gratitude
for the wonderful two years we have
spent here together until then here's to
us class to 2017
the moment you've been all waiting for
we will start with cluster X the
Explorers
[Applause]
Massimo 11q barber Yaris wanna bare
knees
Elizabeth roomfuls Igor full amount of
instead
[Applause]
hojoon Chang pipe mg9 kawatte olive Jen
Maxim gherkin Caroline clusky Lisa Dolan
[Applause]
Julius Shulman Cheney shi-gen Swan Neil
Duncan
Raphael to vol ayala
fault Colin Farrell
[Applause]
greedy coil rubia Hashmi June shoe James
Hudson
[Applause]
Maria max Ivana Ida Nova shravani L
Apocrypha your zdenka le Ava gzhel Jung
rain comin
[Applause]
ESMA karamanski creme Nana
Khalid Troy koltes Alexandra crew blur
on above Kumar
Korean LaHood shreya
Lakshmi monter on Pedro Lorena Jing Lao
Lee Samuel Lee Victor Lee Benjamin
LaSalle Cindy Flynn Chaitanya mandala
Pooh
Antonio mark Samuel Michael men Maria
Chauhan Montenegro Chad majare Edward
Upton
[Applause]
she awhat Punja Tarson gouging Ren
hi-c sauce 3 again Sanu t Sarah WOD
panade allene Subbaraju
cigar sue sri son Josh Jordi son ER e
king oscar taken Stephen toski Magdalena
joy of ska Leonardo that's West
[Applause]
I'm going to get it right sutapa wants
an hour tune Wingate Wellington Arthur
Williams shang wu qian wash you mark gel
Nick ciao
mark Zayed I bottom ah Jokinen now the
yachters of cluster wise one man well
Arya
DeMeo Roca Pablo Artesia Angelo Angelo
Biagio Rafi Andrea Palestrina lupa
beyond Gucci punished for car
Joseph Chauhan G yang twing John Paul
Cisneros Kelsey Crawford
Margaret Culbertson yes Farina sabri's
Alex
Pickman
[Applause]
Justin Fabia Jasper Fontan Alexander von
Falkenhayn Matthew gold Jenna
Greenbaum Christopher Grasso Saurabh
Gupta I'm kit Gupta Jew sounds hon
Robert hell our SEMA tersh Papa Hosking
Junsu Kim at sushi kudo Richard Lehren
[Music]
[Applause]
Sarah Lewis :
Lee Josephine
Lynn Thor's leptin blue awesomo
Matsumoto Zachary Mizell Antonio Moscow
Preston Murray that nickel George Nellis
LaMotta Oh Pelly Krishna Tariq Tatiana
karlova do days Parkville new nanny
Ashley Patti Flavio pen Tanya former n
Neto Oh Sarah Platt own pulse awadhi
Marco Pacino Giulio Patel David Rees
[Applause]
Ricardo ruining Mohnish signing Kunal
Shaw
Stephanie Shaw
[Applause]
finita some pattaya 10 where you sue
Angela Sun grant fan Weingarten Joshua
wolf
Sani whoa Emeline yang Chum
yech and ass Nicholas Uli's Elaine GU
Elaine GU sing sing the zodiacs of
clusters be Salman some Holly Ali Nicole
Italian Frederico for town
Kenard Saini Bilchik ELISA and Foreman
[Applause]
John Byrne David kenmin Clara Corolla
Han Chen Xiao Chen Cristobal June Evan
Cohen Alexandra Cowie Daniel six in
Jordana Freiburg
[Applause]
pedram gas and Lou
Robert Goldman Molly
Gordon char V Gupta
Tobias codelab
Augustus Haney Dylan Hoover Jowan Wang
[Applause]
Kimbrel Hughes McCoy Jen Vanitas Kapoor
Samuel
kokin Dimitri's Cracow Christina
Lawrence you and Zhu Li Pierrot Lepore
Ali Joelle Menzel
Carlos Moreira Auden nervous a you me
okay Alex
O'Neill Joel pack Michaela pantry
Julianne pallucci Almeida
Gabriel Peskin lemon Felipe Pereira KO
Ferreira
Lorenzo Prada Filippo Perini
[Applause]
Barzini Raghu flippy Manuel Ribeiro
Stephen rose Jeannie from see sigan
saffron Sasha Sasha shawl Bowden
Syed shake Neal shelah Galen Simmons her
bard siree Bob
San slit semi Sunita robber shaker -
runyen aqua watt a super pong Alexandra
- Turo
Diedrich fun Houghton Maria Victoria
Riley Wilson Claudia we're Jane to Jing
Jing gal zhengzhou ciao we jus cluster a
the aristocrats Ron Ahuja
Oh gaga Oh Kuroda rofl mangani Kelsey
Brown
William Campbell Lauren Chilton Irene
ciao
Connor cook roshni Deb Leah
Jonathan dill Daniela Dukes Wolski loves
Ellesmere Jerusha frost Kimberly
gitelson
Gloria Maria Gonzales my Yellin Grenada
Eugenio Guzman Jenny halket John harm
[Applause]
Kevin Hennigan Sagar call Erin Kelly and
Crone
Eric laid low Benassi Leppa
mu Lee Henry Lin Daniel Lou Fiona
Lou Aditya Mahajan Royce McAllister
Oscar Oliveros
Benjamin Ostrow Sean Park
I need to fold
Tavares niara Phillips John Pollock
Jennifer poon
[Applause]
Jeffrey poses Thank You Preetha Rajamani
fit Robertson Annika Briella Martin
pilla Sarek Shabet Marco Schneider
Jennifer Sepulveda John Steven camera
and Daniel saw Andrew tag
yeni hang a mirror to volley are y'all
to run in Kimberly texture Julian ting
Sean Troy Linden Volpe Christina weakly
Charles whoo show n-woo
Leo yang Lelouch Zayn Malik I husband
all right beginning to be well done
cluster be beaches Ali Sayyed Abbas in
Gianni Acosta will all filter then are
Bebe's rashik of energy Michael paymon
Aditya PSA Megan chain
Andrew car Juan Diego Carrillo
Melanie Yan Yun Chao joy Chua Stephanie
Davis joseline Doman Anthony Phenix page
Ford Charlie Flanagan Janelle Fox Ani
yeshivah alia korolev Suraj papa
[Applause]
Matthew Hamel Bryan ciarn hinds jr.
Brian Wong
[Music]
[Applause]
Joey an eyeful
Nathan Johnson Rohit Joshi Yoon Bay Kim
Jennifer so Yong Kim nari Kim
Andrew Langer Blair Lee Sonja lived all
Evan Mulenga Daniel Marsh on Christopher
Meszaros Richard Murphy Adam Norris
Megan O'Keefe Conor O'Neill Macias
Orozco one pena Derek Pollock Courtney
Richardson Zachary Rieger Ali Riggins
Thomas Rowe Lindsay there you Aloha and
tan rosanoff Catarina sub ova
or Gil said the jig Tony shoe could he
so Bob Silva Chris Stonerock Christopher
Taylor Jason hi
Mehmet yet
ginger Sonia
Virgil Adam Walder Zachary Wang Sagna
Weaver Madsen
[Applause]
Rufio shoe wrong chain Ryan you long way
Jew cluster C cluster C the commandos
[Applause]
Colleen Behrend Kevin Michael bar bridge
Zachary bar beta Jordan Baron Robert
bishop Christian bull Don John Connor
[Applause]
Jacob Chang
Jacqueline Church well Kevin Colin
[Applause]
[Music]
Russell coud Shane Dickinson learn
Kristen Ashley Dunn gustav eriksson
Amanda Evans
James Graham sadden Nelson and field
that is that francese Christopher frauen
burger
[Music]
Darius Ken McKenzie and cream Victor ha
Rachel ji-woon Han
Consuelo Hernandez Taylor Kegel Carlos
whole Schneider David Johnson Hilary
Kaplan Monica Kelly
Matthew Kennedy erawan Caravan
laddie lolani Joey
Lou Jessica Lucchese Morgan man Markie
Chanel Maps Taylor
Christopher McVitie JT munch Alexander
Nelson hi
nargiz Ian Kristen jay Park
Neil Patel Catrin rosovsky Mary Prager
Deepak Prasad Gandhi Rico Daniel
Rudy ACK
Kate Saxon
[Applause]
Thank You Sabrina
scanned our Noah hers mo Chevy Coleman
shear John
Jungmann song Brian
Tang Talia
hey Victoria
Kevin Alexander Ken Anderson for Castro
Austin um Daniel Vallejo Eden load
injure Lorraine white Erica white
christopher Williams
James William pay Wang Xiao Jing pong
shoe sho Tong Zhuang okay D for disco
all right
the Kira Shakira Addie goon boy a
Alejandro al Bagley cases Karolina
Alegria edward feelin Simon's a name
Christine black Connor bogan
[Applause]
Carolyn brow ver Daniels James
Busby Michael Turkish key and beautiful
baby
James Young CEO he Choi Jung Geun
Elizabeth kalana Edie constable I use
dabba suppor ma gots death Gupta
Phillips day uncor Dube David Farkas
[Applause]
Diego Cabrero Bryan Feldman Miguel
Garcia Ruiz
Miriam Goldenberg Marcel cozily
mark Holloway Misha
if at all June ray Kim
Joshua Scott
Clemmy Laura kornhauser
I'll reel Kurama Leslie why son Kwok
Victoria Natalie why
Jung Hwan Lee Daniels Lewis Darrell Mac
Christopher Marsh Nicholas MELAS Lucia
Mijares Garza Kristen Miller lisandro
Muller
Melanie math okay murder
okuru glue keg another one all right
Kevin Oh sug Oh soggy a
Andre Umrah Mentos Alexander Roma
Sebastian Schmidt Corey sh with a via
Slutsky
Andrew so are Justin
sulemani Christine solitario Brett
Spatafore Robert Karen Thomas Carlson
shipping that Nicholas Turk Etta whoa
Alessandro Volga I just got to slow down
Gao Wei Edward Welch Paul West heart
Michael Wong Jessie young Evans Enel
wrong Jo beginning okay okay II
espionage okay
Rohan am in Alice Andrews Leonardo
Antonio Lewis Joseph aroni
Lisa all Michael's bench em all
Julie Bischoff Christopher black Ronald
Bucca
John Andre loser Anna Castro a soft
journalist Nikki Kimmel
Cece Chen sheer on CeCe
Chen Amanda Davis Juan Diaz
anindya suta Daniel and swim Paul
Spinelli and Ferrer Erica Fox
Elizabeth's cow Adolfo Gomez la Fiera
Xiao Fei goon mullmer gravis mark grow
Alexander Giuliano Emir Hassan Hodgman
Steven Hodgman
okay syena ho googy Sharon quo
Brian lakal kick black allayed Brett
Lacher okay Leila Leila slatted la Java
Darian Alexander Levin Eric Lee Jung
Henry's limb
[Music]
Ashley Lim Michael Liu Jamie page
Myerson
Alexander mill a Kiev Mitchell Alexander
nesterova CH Nicolas O'Sullivan to park
Gregory Pearson Varna ramen Jessica
Rifkin Justin Ross okay great uncial
rooper ole Alan flanker Alex Seidman
Jeffrey schnapps
Brian song Jay bird sang Chanel's Tyler
Johanna
boo Matthew Walker okay
George Wang Lily wick Jessica Winnick
Christopher James Watt ovitch will they
went songs thou okay
after flower power norine alladhina
Michael Apfel Zara Ashraf
Nicola barrel up LaRue sorry forgot the
middle one RT bata
Carly BT Brooklyn a Brandon Chung
Kenneth Clark
Jeffrey Cohen Edward Doherty Daniel M
blood Felix
Fang Jonathan far
Rocio Fernandes rubies Sean box
Zoey box eat on fraser Jennifer Friedman
Emily Garvin mark Shaw
Charlotte Goodrich Frank Hayes
Justin Hong Christina Hopkins Chan
chia-chu Erin Jagger Dan Jose buck V Lee
gulfam car key
Benjamin Carrick Josh cook cue lebra's
Dennis Lee you Ling Li Eric Lagoon
[Applause]
Bernardo Lieberman Katherine Lee Melissa
Lian Alex Megami Andre manda ash vendor
sings Masaru
Meredith Milstein Maria Muller Samuel
Nelson
Joshua's mule Williams noise Navjot
pannu Christopher Perkins Blake Richard
[Applause]
happy Mother's Day Margaret Norman
Lauren Ruth Rose David Rosberg David
Shapiro Gaurav Sharma Laura Shah mark
shouhed David Taylor Courtney
Asher Thompson Julia torque and ginger
thank you Andrew vote Tara Bora
Alexander Whedon Robel wand Rosen
Greg whoo
you enjoy Xu Li young Dan you and both
Zeng okay
one more procedure one more Sophie again
class of 2017 we have two clusters left
and our Award winners I know that many
of you are tempted to leave but if I can
ask you to please stay and share on your
classmates so that their families can
hear them walk across the stage and hear
their names as well we're almost done
[Applause]
technical interruption for one second
Clark she's out of order there now we
thought
Matias Accardi Mizzou animal a Shikoku
anomaly Carmen aria Tiffany Maria Samuel
Sharon Zachary's Wagner Charles
Cavanaugh Warren can be a chorale Illume
John Clark in clues
Benjamin Cowan Michael Costello
[Applause]
Lee cross Malika
seda Tyria
belong to wang taili juice table Oh
potato Camille so Clarence Antoine Cobin
blackjack lovara William Kinmen Cheon PO
Tiffany shoe Jessica Kwang Scott Johnson
Brian serum King Katyn Pernod George
Kazan brat Carney Farina casual wall Lex
key barber Annalyn Kurtz candy Wow
[Applause]
Matthew Levine Noah levy melodies leave
Ashley Mackel
Juliet Mariani yasuharu Matsu no Nikolas
Morgan
Ryan Moses Vladimir Mazzini kick
O'Connor
Alex Park Nicholas Perfetti Nicholas
Chris econo Courtney pitcher Joe quo
arpan ray
[Applause]
Tatyana rancor Benjamin Rome
Clayton Sachs Alexandra and Santana any
song
Gabriel Sousa Aggie
David sign heart Catherine Elise studi
Sonny son Felipe Blue Cross Gotham
quality Divya Rebecca max
Wilner you chuan woo Jin Chi Yan
Jennifer zu cluster eight heroes
Amy I can bomb okay I'll go wall Hannah
amaura ran Arif Miriam book Hachi on
Shula Bakshi Matthew beretta Andrew sour
Kaleo been Laemmle Lauren Spindler
Catherine Canfield we doe kappa Neola
Alex Somesh Tamela shelleyf South Caston
own Tiffany's huge watch n Ezzor turkey
Sean joy
Michelle ciao
Daniel church mrs. Melissa san allow fat
wexel mine savuti croire Seong
[Applause]
I'm going to get it
George de Bourgh's Iran Covarrubias
Kayleigh Penenberg Victor Eng Andrew
England
Melanie Collins jeans along four nines l
love you too Sarah Kowalski see a blonde
Anna Guzman
Sophie ha Raul Papa Lonnie sarin key
Charlie Hill she qu some ways young
Samuel Jones Christie karna D Philip Kim
George slam Lauren Li Jing please
Christian Lopez Theodoric may elephants
might McKissack before
sinara Naga manova Joseph noon
Abraham Nunez Gregory Gregory option of
Eric Peterson Laguna ready
Elizabeth Russell marchello Sal say Kyle
Simon Thomas strand Nicole Sweeney
jouji Sakamoto Patrick TM Diego
teitelbaum
[Applause]
Mark Thompson Pedro and pili or EEB
[Music]
[Applause]
Travis Ballmer Alexander Wolfe Jerry one
Robert visa Samantha
Lally any Herzl Alicia hi Oh Michael
Shapiro
cream Salman
[Applause]
Michael cetera
Charles Pippen clip Ian Smith MRA Kesha
lop Katherine Watson Hilary wiglet sad
Wisman
you turn Yamada
[Applause]
Eric Jen chieh ye Simon Trendelenburg
Patrick Buchanan Karen Alper Christopher
Cunningham Alexander levy
Shawn Talon
Morgan Shattuck Nathaniel's - Suren
Eduardo Cronin sir
Nisha Prasad Kashuk kappa gun salut on a
pom Narayan
Hilary whoa
Michael Conway Charles Eberley graduate
number 788 from the class of 2017
Columbia Business School SID Viswanath
now I realize that I now stand in the
incredibly unenviable position between
this wonderful ceremony and your time
with your family in the reception so
I'll be very brief but I did just want
to say this first echo everything you've
heard all morning and afternoon of what
a pleasure it has been to be with you
and remember that we own you forever so
you are still part of our community and
want to see you second thing I want to
say is this my guess is as you were
preparing to come to this ceremony with
your next big thing somebody probably
said you know what maybe I'd change a
little bit or it's not the right thing
and I don't want you ever to believe
them my late father once said to me and
it has always stuck with me that a
rocket ship leaves for the moon every
day I've always believed it and I'll
close of this story some years ago when
I worked in Washington I was coming back
from Tokyo with the Japanese economy
minister we were working on something
called the trans-pacific partnership
reps you've heard of it we're still
working on it today decades later many
of them we land in Washington and we're
to go to the Capitol to talk about our
handiwork and we passed the Library of
Congress on the Library of Congress is
written past is prologue so talk a
nachus on my Japanese colleague turned
to me and said what does that mean so I
launched into one of my kind of
long-winded college professor II kind of
riffs and the cab driver lost it and
turned around and said you know what
he's trying to say to you is you ain't
seen nothing yet
that's our message for you graduates one
final round of applause for you
our reception is in the Ansel Plaza
please let the graduates file out with
the procession first and we will see you
over there thank you
[Applause]